selon lui l'effet aurait eu lieu le 10
février 2013
ce jour-là il serait allé chercher
Marceline chez elle pour l'emmener chez
sa fille
sur la route elle l'aurait énervée
[Musique]
il se serait alors arrêté
et leur est étranglé avec un torchon
[Musique]
dans la commune de Divion dans le
Pas-de-Calais
Thérèse avait son petit rituel
chaque jour après le déjeuner elle
apporta un repas à sa voisine Marceline
tous les jours comme ça mettez son futur
a dû rentrer
sur la table dans le faitout des restes
de cassoulet ou de boeuf bourguignon que
tes rêves offre généreusement à sa
voisine ses revenus sont tellement
modestes que Marceline saute souvent des
repas
j'avais pas mangé à midi et puis j'ai
rencontré tous les jours
mais un jour le faitout reste toute la
journée sur le bord de la fenêtre ce qui
intrigue immédiatement Thérèse
il y avait personne
mon fils tout rouge
c'est la première fois que Marceline ne
récupère pas son repas
l'une des dernières à l'avoir vu c'est
sa belle-fille Virginie
à la banque avec mon mari on était le
ramené chez elle et après on a pu une
nouvelle de ma belle-mère
un quai de ne pas avoir de nouvelles
ton domicile
il y avait deux chiens dans la salle à
chien dans la cuisine
pas répondu je dois être parti faire des
papiers et arrêtez au soir elle a été
toujours pas là le mercredi on y a été
au matin et on se fera à 20h j'ai appelé
les pompiers parce que ça m'inquiétait
les pompiers enfoncent la porte à
l'intérieur il trouve ses trois chiens
mais aucune trace de Marceline
que s'est-il passé la vieille dame de 67
ans ne s'absente jamais sans prévenir
aurait-elle fait une mauvaise rencontre
Marceline bedinier grandi dans le
Pas-de-Calais où elle met au monde 6
enfants tous deux paires différents
Tim d'un lourd traumatisme dans son
enfance elle est très fragile
psychologiquement
les services sociaux la jugent inapte à
éduquer ses enfants et lui en retire la
garde
Sabine et sa dernière fille même si elle
n'a pas été élevée par Marceline elle
reste très proche d'elle
toujours donner le maximum comme toute
maman pourrait donner à son enfant même
si on avait moins de temps parce qu'on
était chez ma grand-mère je la voyais
tous les jours elle venait tous les
jours à s'occuper de nous du mieux
qu'elle pouvait malgré qu'on n'était pas
24 heures sur 24 avec elle au fil du
temps Marceline devient heureuse
grand-mère d'une vingtaine de petits
enfants
Jeffrey est l'un d'eux
héberger quelques temps chez Marceline
il se souvient que toute la famille
venait souvent lui rendre visite
j'étais fort proche d'elle c'était comme
ma mère quoi
par exemple pour faire ses courses et on
parle à qui venait un peu tout le monde
connaît l'aider on était pas chacun
notre tour qu'on leur donnait un coup de
main
parmi ceux qui viennent le plus souvent
chez Marceline il y a son fils Christian
et sa belle-fille Virginie
mais aussi l'un de ses petits-enfants
Jérémy
ce dernier est particulièrement
attentionné envers sa grand-mère
[Musique]
la banque à l'origine il a dit ouais ben
j'arrive tout de suite
c'est service ne seraient pas forcément
dénué d'intérêt
même si Marceline ne perçoit qu'une
petite pension d'invalidité pour vivre
elle en fait profiter ses petits enfants
[Musique]
elle était trop gentil en fait trop
gentil avec tout le monde si elle
voulait pas le dire je sais pas mais
elle savait pas dire non donc celui qui
savait il savait comment faire pour
qu'elle dise oui quoi
Marceline bédigné et donc une grand-mère
généreuse et entourée apparemment sans
histoire
pourtant un dimanche le 10 février 2013
elle disparaît mystérieusement sans
laisser de traces
deux jours plus tard au milieu de ce
bois son corps est retrouvé
partiellement brûlé
l'autopsie révèle que la vieille dame
est morte étranglée
son sac à main et son téléphone portable
ont disparu
sa famille et sous le choc
était dans l'incompréhension de
qui a pu faire ça pourquoi
on comprenait pas
pour nous c'était pas possible que
quelqu'un puisse lui faire du mal pour
quelle raison surtout
pendant plusieurs jours les gendarmes ne
trouvent aucun indice mais en détail va
les mettre sur une piste en étudiant les
mouvements bancaires de Marceline il
découvre qu'un retrait de 90 euros a été
effectué avec sa carte bleue trois jours
après sa mort
la caméra de vidéo surveillance permet
d'identifier l'auteur de ce retrait bien
qu'il tente de camoufler son visage
stupeur il s'agit de Jérémy Lorion le
petit-fils de Marceline toujours si
attentionné envers elle
est aussi tôt interpellé et placé en
garde à vue Jérémy est-il réellement
impliqué dans le meurtre de sa
grand-mère
âgé de 25 ans le jeune homme mène en
apparence une vie paisible il vit en
couple depuis trois ans et vient d'être
papa
c'est la photo de Jérémy avec sa fille
celle qui était sa compagne à cette
époque a accepté de nous parler mais à
condition de garder l'anonymat la jeune
femme se souvient avec nostalgie du
début de leur relation
je pensais vraiment avoir trouvé l'homme
de ma vie quoi je pensais faire ma vie
avec lui on avait une intention de se
marier
là vers moi des projets quoi mais le
conte de fées ne va pas durer selon son
ancienne compagne Jeremy délaisse peu à
peu sa vie de famille sans emploi il
passe ses journées ici à jouer avec ses
copains et à fumer du cannabis
mais Jérémy ne compte pas uniquement sur
ses copains en fait il profiterait aussi
de la gentillesse de sa grand-mère
il lui avait demandé de l'argent à
prêter elle lui avait prêté
c'était une grossesse
comme ça donc c'est vrai que pour elle
300 euros c'était beaucoup d'argent pour
les gendarmes la mort de Marceline
serait sans doute liée à une histoire
d'argent
Jérémy en demandait-il toujours plus à
sa grand-mère celle-ci aurait-elle
refusé d'en prêter davantage
[Musique]
en tout cas la compagne de Jérémy se
souvient d'un détail intrigant le jour
où Marceline disparaît le jeune homme
rentre chez lui une partie du visage
brûlé il m'a dit que c'était un aliment
joint qui sont briquet était cassé il
l'avait modifié salut avait brûlé ses
cheveux et ses sourcils et
enfin pour moi c'était tout à fait
possible
des sourcils brûlés un corps calciné des
problèmes d'argent et une carte bleue
volée pour les gendarmes les indices
s'accumulent à l'encontre de Jérémy
d'ailleurs au bout de deux jours de
garde à vue le jeune homme craque et
avoue avoir tué sa grand-mère
selon lui l'effet aurait eu lieu le 10
février 2013
ce jour-là il serait allé chercher
Marceline chez elle pour l'emmener chez
sa fille
sur la route elle l'aurait énervée
[Musique]
il se serait alors arrêté
il aurait étranglée avec un torchon
lors de son interrogatoire il déclare
aux gendarmes
je me suis arrêté sur le bas-côté et
j'ai commencé à l'étrangler une fois
qu'elle était morte je lui ai dit que
j'étais désolé
pour son avocat Maître Dubout Jérémy
n'était pas dans son état normal
son geste il explique c'est un coup de
folie
qu'il s'est il peut pas l'expliquer par
de la colère par aucun sentiment de ce
genre là simplement sur l'instant parce
qu'il avait consommé une forte dose de
whisky qui avait consommé de la cocaïne
et
sur l'énervement parce qu'il y avait un
moment très précis où sa grand-mère là
énervé il dit qu'il allait être anglaise
pour moi
prix de panique Jérémy aurait ensuite
abandonné le corps de Marceline dans le
bois le plus proche
pour effacer ses empreintes il l'aurait
ensuite aspergé avec un bidon d'essence
c'est en mettant le feu qu'il se serait
brûlé une partie des sourcils et des
cheveux
pour les enquêteurs cette version des
faits est parfaitement crédible mais
aujourd'hui encore les proches de Jérémy
ont des doutes
j'ai du mal à croire vraiment c'est le
cas notamment de sa tante Sabine
moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'il pouvait
pas faire ça seul donc
j'ai aucune preuve j'ai remis ne veut
rien dire donc
après la reconstitution a prouvé qu'il
pouvait le faire seul j'ai toujours du
mal à le croire
face aux gendarmes Jérémy va d'ailleurs
changer de version à de multiples
reprises
il va même jusqu'à accuser son père
d'être l'auteur du meurtre
j'ai vu mon père qui sortait de la
chambre de ma grand-mère
[Musique]
elle avait la tête violette et la langue
qui pendait
mon père était en panique il m'a dit de
l'aider
accusé par son fils Christian est à son
tour plaçant en garde à vue
pour sa femme Virginie si Jérémy accuse
son père c'est dans l'espoir qu'il
accepte de porter le chapeau à sa place
son père était toujours là pour le
défendre
sur un vol son père et aurait dit que
c'était lui qui l'avait fait mais là on
parle pas d'un vol on parle d'un meurtre
son père il prend avec lui il dit qu'il
était avec comme ça il se prenait moi
pour la première fois le père de Jérémy
accepte de parler de ce drame très
secoué il a déjà fait plusieurs
tentatives de suicide
comment vous êtes défendu alors
que j'étais pour rien ça j'ai pas arrêté
de le dire
mais le moment je réfléchis beaucoup que
j'ai tout un mauvais père je sais pas
Jérémy mais finalement son père hors de
cause et affirme avoir tué seul sa
grand-mère sur un coup de folie mais le
problème c'est que le jeune homme
n'arrête pas de changer de version même
son avocat est perdu je sais pas du tout
comment le procès va se passer mais on
peut avoir des surprises moi je sais pas
ce qui va s'y Jérémy va nous lâcher des
bombes s'il va nous dire des choses qui
nous avaient pas encore dit ça j'en sais
absolument rien mais moi je suis pas
satisfait de la façon de l'histoire est
écrite j'arrive pas à m'expliquer
pourquoi il accusait son père si
véritablement il y a personne d'autre
incarcéré depuis deux ans dans cette
maison d'arrêt Jérémy Lorion est
poursuivi pour vol avec violence ayant
entraîné la mort
si il est reconnu comme seul coupable il
risque l'emprisonnement à perpétuité
[Applaudissements]
lors de son procès qui débutera le 22
juin prochain devant la cour d'assises
de Saint-Omer
ses proches espèrent enfin connaître
toute la vérité sur ce drame familial
[Musique]